il ya quelques qui a voulu me faire un
défi il voulait faire le défi ping pong
chez eux
je vous le dis si qu'elle gagne alors
séquelles qui achètera des places pour
son spectacle pour tout public
d'accord d'accord c'est exact si c'est
moi non non non non non non tu viens de
te retrouver cyril par douelle c'est
vrai si je perds je perds si tu perds je
vis tout le monde exactement et surpris
tout le monde à mon spectacle où tu veux
d'ailleurs d'accord l'invite d'accord et
si je perds j'invite tout le monde à
mons hamas est parti à lorient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on fait ça en cinq points en cinq
points ça me va cinq points juste
excusez moi j'aimerai savoir parmi les
chroniqueurs
parmi tout le monde vous êtes pour qui
l'image ragga taille et hugo paroisse et
vous avez-vous évidemment il anime mais
je peux dire est en gynéco de se taire
merci merci donc ça m'a donc il serait
moins un petit lui parler dire et c'est
dieu sait si je suis pour ksm
bravo merci gilles a toujours procédé
qui me paye mon coeur mais vous c'est
pour vous mais pourquoi taper les mots
c'est pour vous ça fait dix ans j'ai pas
joué un joli on peut dire que je suis là
outsiders comme un rival direct
on y joue pas on y va direct un bon
style mais tu vois ça atteint à zéro on
peut mettre les pieds au fait merci à
isabelle morini-bosc on me remet la
table n'est pas homologué la serbie
combien de comprend 23 manioc au [ __ ]
c'est pas jouer c'est pas d'étape ça
c'est pas l'étape de l'onu je te jure
que s'ils savaient combien de zéros
alors on croise
ok moi ça fait plaisir croît c'est pas
fini les patins parce qu il est pas fini
son bac mardi
vous voyez vous
aulas allait pas mal je sais bien allez
allez va aller années n'ont qu'à
travailler à trois balles de match ça
sent pas bon ça sent clairement pas bon
c'est parti d'une ue à besoin quand je
disais j'avais tout le monde c'est de la
lettre a à la lettre à m
[Applaudissements]
ah bon